notre monde c'est squeeze et aujourd'hui
ridicule et aujourd'hui pour changer un
peu des vidéos à plusieurs de d'habitude
on se retourne en pâture garry's mod et
sur counter strike mais sur just cause 2
voilà et c'est absolument n'importe quoi
voilà c'était les infos du jour je
retourne dans mes bras je ramène sur
l'île par contre quand je dis je te
ramène sur l'île c'est vraiment sur
l'île
pardon excusez moi yann au petit thé ou
veolia eau qui va tuer c'était la
branche ancien comique a demandé maman
me canonica à quelle vengeance de me
cacher j'avais tué d'après ce rire ça
veut dire est qu à venir ouais j'en ai
dit qu à mais il m'a volé mon dicton
marque de dessus et un dedans à temps
mais c'est compliqué attendait les mecs
j'ai un problème j'ai un problème je
crois je me rebelle droit [ __ ] on a un
problème et je suis tombé aussi bien
actuel 6ème chérèque
y a personne tu peux nous approcher le
chèque qu'on regarde le debout c'est le
parti elle ou allez vas-y vas-y j'y vais
j'y vais vers l'infini on ne va pas je
me suis jetée ianu yakin sur l'avion la
région à l'autre je fais baj
si je frappe la balle âge je te vois ce
quiz hip hop je dis pas parce qu'un tel
accident ne suis pas ami avec cette
impression de vitesse
je tire au genre et pas du mécano
décalotter où j'ai pris un bateau pour
vous rejoindre
ap ap le plus petit des bateaux médias a
plu sur shift pour accélérer vikarby
qu'at il fait de la pêche qui s'élance
jusqu'au bout à tanger 1500 $ je peux
prendre à winston machin temps je teste
mais nous sommes exposés mais je me suis
explosé avec [ __ ] j'avais payé ce
bateau mille dollars au nom mais j'ai
encore pris mme bouayad mes mecs je te
vendent sur le bateau et yann eliès je
suis je suis aussi mon mec je te vois la
tête de tous âges et aquatiques sur la
touche start intel 1 2 3 et wii mais
faites pas ça faisait ça va donner au
demeurant pas si ça va exploser yade
et si l'on y compris ça explose et yann
ashkenazi suivez moi on me tire dessus
millions c'est me arrête médias mais
nous avec le bateau et c'est n'importe
quoi [ __ ] mais qui plonge quoi il se
prend pour un dauphin les vols aller je
me faisait kidnapper par mon propre
bateau je suis là je suis là mais j'ai
fait aïe et pourquoi tu me font chier
tout le temps j'ai pas fait gaffe est
parti allez c'est parti les garçons
crash sans quoi que ce soit sous mao
yushi en dessous nous regarde regarde à
gauche je vais ressortir bonjour on va
bientôt se dégage mais ça les scooters
voilà wanadoo
on peut ensuite art un problème c'est
pas mal d'amateurs du genre depuis cole
mais change en limousine
j'arrive de sécurité routière et gallas
cap mais avant tout c'est mika quéveau
la jeunesse parcourir aucun de vous
trois n'avait remarqué je n'étais pas
encore mon père est parti sans quoi bon
bah c'est moi qui m'occupe de la radio
en jeu mais chérie fm
j'aime tout à son arrivée la chanson ah
bon alors là c'est l'histoire de deux
buts
[Musique]
voilà il a raté regarde mur dans trois
demain et quelle idée de venir à la avec
une chemise hawaïenne sérieux et non non
je le sens bien à 100 balles si je la
sens bien ici j'ai zappé la dacia et
expliquer comment on fait parce que ça a
l'air de marcher centre de voitures au
revoir riccardo non mais sérieux
mesdames je suis sorti de là non mais
c'est lui qui a fait ça c'est que tu
fais tu perds que nos jeunes aient
disparu c'est moi je suis là oui majesté
envoyé un moyen de 38 oui ma jeep quoi
dégâts comment ça marche
waouh on est visée on est visée gros et
puis au point de demain mika c'est pas
moi c'est sérieux arrête un squeeze est
mort de michael chopra chat encore ça
marche et c'est relié tu es prêt on
n'essaye pas tomber ok on essaie de pas
trouvé ok on a aussi un bon final grave
c'est du gros riffs
du gros drift ya pas de métier je te mau
pression pétales a pas de problème mais
c'est quoi ce matériau du caté une
météorite en gagnant je suis grand
survivants puisque c'est comme ça
okc les places regarde moi ça puisque
c'est comme ça tu vas laisser ça va ça
va il a décrit datera vita je sors avec
y'a un mec dans l'hélico il est parti
avec toi mon cher c'est le tout se fait
tous afin d'atteindre hélico [ __ ] non
mais non on put et trois pouces et
pardon j'ai la santé je vais tenter mais
je n'en connais pas ton inutilement et
l'alien mais j'y suis là ok c'est pas
plus tard pourquoi hommage et bien qu un
bon j'ai redécouvert en charge locaux
yao jian tong ont jeté des insurgés des
lits clos
je veux voir ta beauté je suis là à
temps par contre tu me pointe avec très
beau mais surtout pas regarder les
enfants s'il vous plaît ou à l'ignorance
et la pire des souffrances
je sais pas vu que je à richardson monde
d'accord bah ils m'ont piqué mon avion
d'accord trailer on mettrait bien je le
sais quoi
non qu'est ce qui s'est passé c'est toi
médias café ça j'ai peint alors oui kg
la mode solo en kapisa près tout sur la
rambarde ont fait de sa part est un
bateau en même temps ok jamais qu'à
tétreault prochainement il va se passer
un truc pas bien vous êtes prêts ouais
ouais je vais dire à un deux ou trois
clics vous cliquez ok 1 2 3 ou en
week-end
à vos repères mais en plus super youtube
ah merde bon cette fois je me trompe pas
je prends un bateau vide on prenait le
nom mais non votre attention s'il vous
plaît tous en place lançant un deux
trois clics et c'est moi c'est parti
c'est parti et les super idée d'un homme
et non mais je suis moche non mais je
pensais pas que le bateau il sera vieux
piquer comme ça vous appuyez sur
chiffres dès que le bateau amarré au
quai 1 2 3 clics et chief direct pour
avoir un peu c'est bon les gars de la
baronnie sur la rivière et voilà les
gens c'est déjà la fin de cette vidéo
sur just cause 2 ce soir s'il aura plus
c'est le cas n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo
comme d'habitude c'est vraiment plaisir
c'est ça qui vous aura aussi plus qu'un
charisma carpenter cette action soutient
aucun adibou je vous revois dans la
prochaine vidéo oui oui tiens tout le
monde
[Musique]